darlington
this is the fifth hustings in our
nationwide tour and for me it's good to
be home in the northeast where i was
born and brought up in sunderland
thank you everyone for attending this
evening
these hustings are for us
for the members of the conservative
party to take part in a great exercise
of democracy where we get to choose our
leader
no tv debates
just here tonight for you to ask
questions
he or she will be announced on the 5th
of september and as with the party of
government will become prime minister
very soon afterwards
as ian dale who moderated many of the
hustings in 2019 said and i quote
i found chairing the hustings a
surprisingly positive experience the
members really put the two candidates
through their paces
and asked some very searching questions
so i ask you tonight to make your
question searching
to make them succinct
and to ask questions and not to make
statements
one question each please so that more of
the audience have an opportunity to
grill our candidates
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire to fulfill our 2019 manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about achieving that in a very
different world from 2019
post brexit
post covert in uncertain times
internationally look at ukraine and
taiwan and where our union as a nation
is being challenged
so i'm sure tonight that you want to
test our candidates to seek to establish
their strengths
and to see who you think is best capable
of running our great country
as we're all conservatives here
i hope so
i know that you will be respectful of
our two candidates and keep your
questions positive
as you know the ballot has opened
you can cast your vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online or you can
choose traditional snail mail and if you
do post then please remember to put a
stamp on the envelope
you should receive your ballot paper by
the 11th of august and then if you
haven't please contact your constituency
chairman and we'll get it sorted out for
you
my hope is that this evening will give
you more clarity about how to cast that
ballot
i hope you go away enthused and
energized in your commitment to helping
our great party win the next election we
need your support
finally i want to thank our darlington
chairman pauline kelly down here
and now ladies and gentlemen without
further ado let's get on with the show
please welcome andrew stevenson chairman
of the conservative party
[Applause]
good evening and thank you for coming to
our fifth nationwide hustlings here in
darlington
i'm delighted to be joined by so many
members of our party at another sold out
event where we're giving you our members
the chance to put your questions
directly to the two candidates
all these events are also available
online so welcome to those of you
joining us virtually
over the last couple of days i've been
getting out and about across the
northeast campaigning with conservative
activists in seats like northwest durham
bishop auckland hartley pool
red car in cleveland
and with our excellent new deputy
chairman matt vickers
[Applause]
these seats alongside several others in
the region are key to our victory at the
next general election so it's been great
to campaign alongside so many of our
dedicated party members
we've all seen the incredibly strong
slate of candidates we've had for this
contest
together the most diverse range of
candidates for any leadership election
in british history
labour would love to have a female
leader but we could be about to have our
third female prime minister before
they've had one
or our first prime minister of asian
heritage the second conservative prime
minister from minority background
[Applause]
i'm staying neutral in this contest
as are all about
as are all of our hard-working party
staff but i do believe we have two
fantastic candidates either can tackle
the big issues our country is facing
taking us forward together
and we are the world's most successful
political party and that is down to our
ideas the support of our members and our
record
our current prime minister boris johnson
has shown that a conservative government
can rise to the challenges of today
getting brexit done delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe
protecting 14 million jobs during the
pandemic and leading the world in
supporting ukraine in standing up to
putin that is a truly historic record
which our next leader will build upon
with the support of our members
before we hear from each of our
candidates let us remember when a strong
conservative government is so important
the alternative is a labor-led
government likely in coalition with the
liberal democrats and the snp
which would risk the integrity of our
united kingdom
labour would have never got brexit done
they voted against tax cuts for
low-income families they voted against
more investment in our nhs and they
voted against protecting our borders and
tackling the vile people smugglers
and now they want sequia stala to run
our country
when he can't even get his party members
on side with the hard-working majority
of british people against labour's union
paymasters
with shadow ministers even joining
picket lines it's very clear that labour
still isn't working
remember when labour last left
government they admitted there was no
money left
and no labor government has ever left
office with unemployment lower than when
they came to power
that is what is at stake
it is our next leader who will
relentlessly continue to deliver for the
british people
leading the way in standing up for our
ideals and our partners on the world
stage
uniting the country and this concerted
party
i know you all want to hear from the two
candidates to help you decide who to
choose to lead our great party and our
country
so with no further ado let me hand over
to your host here in darlington tom
newton dunn thank you
good evening
[Music]
this is like pantomime already thank you
very much oh no they won't oh yes they
will
uh briefly introduce myself folks uh and
i'm not going to give you a long speech
i promise you've already had two my name
is tom newton i've been a political
journalist for
uh most of my working life uh 13 of
those years i've been a political editor
so i've covered a few tory leadership
contests uh down the ages you do them
once every three years so we'll be back
in 2025
uh i'm booking my hotel or already
that's you lot on me
um oh no it isn't
golf again
uh
i don't need to tell you how important
the red wall is seats like darlington uh
the last had because
in 1992
one young michael fallon defeated by one
young alan milber doesn't make all of us
feel very old uh thinking about that
it's a fact to say that obviously
darlington turned blue in 2019 as did 50
55 or so others
if your party can't keep those red wall
seats
in 2024 where the next general election
is you won't hold on to power i think
that's a cast iron fact of british
politics now you also don't need me to
tell you this is not the leafy
prosperous south there's some prosperous
people up here but also some people in
quite a bit of trouble two little
statistics i just wanted to share with
you an opinion poll by more in common
last weekend found that across the uk
33 say they're either struggling or not
coping at all
in red wall areas across the middle of
the north like these that number is 46
the other statistic utility bills alone
are absorbing as much as 25
of households pre-tax income in red wall
areas that you also don't need to tell
you is an awful lot so
i hope tonight of this first things
we'll do a little bit differently than
perhaps other huskies will all ask me
and you some very direct questions of
the candidates precisely how it is
they're going to help those people in
real trouble not in september not
october but right now
we'll get to all that and the fun will
have questions a bit later on though
first
let's hear from the first campaign you
should sue max
[Applause]
faces in the crowd good evening everyone
i am ridiculously excited to be here um
so tonight i'm here to tell you a story
it's my story
and it starts
with the fact that i had never voted
conservative before i voted for myself
um in the space of a year i went from
someone who had never before voted
conservative to an elected conservative
county councillor in a safe labour ward
as part of the joint administration we
took power from labour in county durham
for the first time
so my story started with covert at the
beginning of the pandemic i was a small
business owner absolutely terrified of
what was presenting itself in front of
me so i reached out to my local mp
richard holden
and richard invited me to join zoom
conversations with other small business
owners and crucially cabinet ministers
from the back of these conversations the
government bounce back loan was created
now
because of one single loan
my franchise business lingo top was
safeguarded
as with the 60 businesses of my
franchisees and 130 jobs
and all of that was thanks to rishi
sulak
i couldn't believe it rishi had listened
a politician had listened to me and it
was even the chancellor
it was my very first positive political
experience
because there's someone born and bred in
the northeast i'm not hiding this accent
as someone born and bred in the
northeast
we're just absolutely used to being
ignored
we were sidelined again and again and
even when we had a labor prime minister
down the road in sedgefield what
happened nothing
so which politician has done more for
the northeast than anyone else rishi
sunap
from little things like coming and
visiting my ward and meeting local
businesses up in dulles lane in concert
through to the immense amount of work
done in t side rishi even dead to bring
a whole government department up from
london and bring it right here in
darlington right here
you guys are making me feel so good
in 2019 the northeast bordered
conservative like never before and when
i was knocking on doors people were
saying that for the first time ever they
felt important and listened to just like
rishi had made me feel and he really
inspired me to get involved in politics
we need to keep up that momentum
we need to keep that red ball smashed
let's smash it a bit more
and we need a safe pair of hands and i
know as our prime minister rishi will
continue to listen and act in the best
interests of everyone not just in the
northeast but all over the country
[Applause]
rishi has proven that he has all of the
values and attributes needed to lead our
great country he's honest he has
integrity he stays calm under pressure
my goodness did you see him in covert
covet
and he is brave and bold and makes the
big decisions such as furlough
and also as his experience as chancellor
and in his working life in finance
before that
i know that he has all of the skills
needed to tackle inflation
control borrowing and keep interest
rates down for families up and down the
country
thankfully
my story has a happy ending
my business and my team came through
covered thanks to rishi's support
and i know he's the best placed person
to be our prime minister and crucially
win the next general election and you
know why i know that
because if he can inspire this concert
last to do a complete 180 then taking on
what she's taking on a daddy said where
she's worth it
but taking on kia stammer is an absolute
piece of cake thank you
[Music]
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work
patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
rishi has been a fantastic friend to me
and to darlington who's committing to
leveling up not just in t side but
across the country as well which is
extremely important to me ritchie as
prime minister will know how to
capitalize on the benefits of brexit we
get it that our towns and villages need
as much investment as our cities
please welcome rishi sunac
[Applause]
good evening
good evening everyone gosh it is
fantastic to be with you here tonight
not least because for the first time in
a long time i've actually had a couple
of nights sleep in my own bed in north
american it is so great to be home
[Applause]
my parents are staying with us at the
moment and i realized i've been
campaigning a lot when last night i was
talking to them and i started telling
them that my dad was a gp and my mum
just before we get going i want to take
a moment to celebrate the extraordinary
success of our party of all of you here
in the northeast
because look at this
we've got ben houchin re-elected we've
got members of parliament in bishop
auckland in bligh
in sedgefield
in stockton in darlington in red car
we've got councillors everywhere and for
the first time in a hundred years we
kick labor off durham council
[Applause]
now i i wouldn't be here tonight if it
wasn't actually for one of those people
that i just mentioned he's a good friend
he's been a great supporter
his name is matthew vickers he's the mp
for stockton town
it gives me just this opportunity to say
thank you to matt for all the support
he's given me he was my first agent when
i was first elected now but you all know
him as a fantastic campaigner because
he's campaigned to put more conservative
councillors on stockton council
he's campaigned to get himself elected
in stockton south but what you don't
know
is that his most important campaign
is to get the palmo on the menu in
parliament
i'll tell you this matt
if this if this works out for me we
won't just do palmos in parliament we'll
be serving them off the cabinet table in
downing street
[Music]
wonderful as that is the real reason
that i'm standing in front of you today
is because our country did something
extraordinary for my family it welcomed
them here as immigrants 60 years ago and
allowed them to build a better life
now i was brought up with a simple set
of values the first among those is that
family means everything to me because we
all know the bombs of family are far
greater than anything
any government could ever hope to
replicate it and we as conservatives
must never ever forget that
now in my family we prioritized hard
work as the way to forge ahead and when
i was working for my mum in her shop i
was out and about in the community
delivering medicines and seeing the
power of her small business to provide
jobs and opportunity in our local
community
now for my parents there was one thing
above all that they thought could give
their kids a better future and that was
simple
it was education
and that's why i passionately believe
that the best way we reduce inequality
the best way that we spread opportunity
indeed the best way that we transform
people's lives is by ensuring that the
birthright of every child is a
world-class education
and that's not just about schools it's
not even and especially not just about
university it's about fantastic
apprenticeships and technical education
including the brand new incredible
technical institute we are putting right
here in the north east
so those
those in a nutshell are my values
patriotism family
service hard work aspiration and i know
they are all of your values too and
that's because they're conservative
values and that's why i want to be your
leader and prime minister because i want
to put those conservative values into
action to build a better britain and
just as our country allowed my family to
provide opportunities for me
i want to do the same for everyone for
your children and grandchildren
but how are we going to do that well we
need to do three things we need to
restore trust
we need to rebuild the economy
and we need to reunite our country
now restoring trust starts by being
honest and as you can see in this
leadership contest i have not made my
life easy with the things i am saying
but i believe that our country does face
some real challenges and i want to be
straight with everyone about what they
are and what is going to be required to
fix them now even though that's not easy
it is honest and that for me is what
leadership is all about
but in order to restore trust we also
have to deliver on the things that
matter to people that's why i've found
out a radical plan to start reforming
the nhs so we can focus less on how much
money we're putting into it and more on
the quality of the healthcare we're
getting out of it
it's why it's why
it's why i put the treasury in
darlington because i wanted to send a
loud message to whitehall that there is
more to the north than
[Applause]
you this if this manchester out it won't
just be called the treasury campus in
darlington it will be the downing street
campus in darlington
but it's also why i want to stand up to
this lefty work culture that seems to
want to cancel our histories our values
and our women
and
it's why i set out a bold and radical
plan to finally get to grips with
illegal migration because for too long
all of us have been watching on our tv
screens scenes that are simply
unacceptable of people coming here
illegally now with my plan under my
leadership we will finally get a grip of
that situation stop the boats restore
trust and take back control of our
borders
when it comes to rebuilding the economy
i don't need to tell all of you what the
number one challenge is you know and
it's inflation
and we must get a grip of it because
we've seen this story before we know
that inflation is the enemy it makes
everyone poorer
it pushes up mortgage rates it erodes
people's hard-earned savings and
pensions now of course i'm always as i
have done as child so they're going to
help those who need our help with the
cost of living and this autumn we can
cut vat on energy bills and i will go
further but what i won't do
is pursue policies that risk making
inflation worse and last far longer
especially
if those policies
simply amount to borrowing tens and tens
of billions of pounds putting them on
the country's credit card and asking our
kids and our grandkids to pick up the
town
it's not responsible and it's certainly
not conservative
but i am going to cut taxes in this
parliament for the first time in 16
years we are going to cut income tax
because as conservatives we need to make
sure that hard work always pays and i'm
going to go on cutting income tax for
years to come but we're going to do that
responsibly
we're going to do it by being tough on
public spending and by growing our
economy and this autumn i'm going to
radically reform business taxes to
actually
cut those taxes for businesses that are
doing the right thing businesses here in
the northeast that are investing
expanding their manufacturing capacity
innovating to create new products and
services putting in advanced
robotics and automation because that's
how you drive growth in a modern economy
but i'm also going to take advantage of
our brexit opportunities now i know
there's been some talk in this
leadership contest and i've been amused
to discover or read that apparently i'm
not i'm not a proper brexiteer
well i'll tell you i was proud to
actually vote for brexit in the first
place
i was then proud to figure out what are
we going to do with this and as a
backbencher i came up with a new policy
a radical new policy that's going to
attract jobs and investment to the
united kingdom and then i went one
further as chancellor i worked with
jacob young i worked with ben houchin
and we delivered it and we put the
biggest freeport in the country right
here in tucson
and when i did my budget last year do
you know how concluded my budget i
talked about the future economy that i
wanted to build in the united kingdom
and i talked about t-style i talked
about what we were doing here i talked
about the jobs we were creating the
investment we were attracting the
innovation that was happening in vaccine
manufacturing in the new renewable
industries of the future and i said i
wanted to deliver that same energy and
optimism that we are doing here across
the united kingdom and if you give me
the chance that's exactly what i will do
because where the northeast leads the
rest of the country will follow
because
in just a couple of years time we need
to reunite our country
we need to do something
friends that has never
ever been done before we have to make
british political history by winning a
fifth election in a row
now i know
that working together all of us we can
do it
but it's going to require us to appeal
to swing voters everywhere in the north
in the south remain areas brexit areas
rural areas urban areas labor areas
liberal areas wales and scotland and i
passionately believe and all the
evidence supports that i am the
candidate that gives our party the best
opportunity of beating labor and
ensuring kirst alma never walks through
the door of 10 downing stream
and in conclusion let me just say this
you saw me as chancellor in the pandemic
act boldly quickly radically
to support jobs and businesses and to
ensure that our economy was remained
resilient
in face of the biggest shock we suffered
in 300 years
well i will bring that same sense of
urgency and grip to every other
challenge that government faces to build
the better britain that i talked about
where our kids can walk safely on the
streets at night where our schools and
apprenticeships are the envy of the
world and providing opportunity for our
young people where our nhs is reformed
and efficient and there for us when we
need where our economy is like decide
creating jobs and prosperity in every
part of the country
but beyond that i promise you this
i will work my socks off i will give you
my everything to ensure that each and
every one of you here tonight can always
feel enormously proud of the
conservative government that i will be
privileged to lead
seven years ago i stood in front of a
group of people
in richmond in north yorkshire
and asked them
to select me as their candidate and they
did me the greatest honor of my life
in allowing me to be their member of
parliament
and many of them are here tonight and
i'm so grateful for the love the
kindness and support they have given me
that led me to this place
and now
i ask you all the same thing humbly for
your support not just to be your next
party leader but also the next prime
minister of our great country thank you
very much
[Applause]
folks a quick intermission a
conservative party can only afford one
microphone these days
as you know you're a bit hard up so
while that's being switched backstage uh
i will talk to you very quickly so this
time hustling has been broadcast by talk
tv tonight currently on the program i
present the news test which is the alan
newsbreaker you'll know watch avidly i
know to help us
i'd like to do a very quick show of
hands don't worry i've had this signed
off by your party uh all of those who
still don't know which candidate they'd
like to vote for please raise your hands
now
that's really interesting by my
primitive camp i'd say that's probably
40 or so percent looking up in the gold
sir
everyone up in the top floor but they're
all journalists
most people like me we don't choose
that's really interesting thank you
around 45 still
we hope tonight obviously uh helps
without further ado let's move on now to
the liz trust campaign
[Applause]
good evening
isn't it lovely to be here uh and thank
you all for coming out uh to join this
extraordinary event that the
conservative party is doing to choose
not only our next leader but of course
the next prime minister i just want to
correct something that angela said she
said there was a happy ending to her
story i don't think there is i think
she's going to be standing as an mp
before we know it it was a joy to hear
that fantastic story from her about her
political journey and indeed that
incredible incredible result in county
durham which i think tells the whole
world that nothing is impossible for the
conservative party we bring our energy
our passion and we know
that voters understand what that means
so i'm really excited that we're here
tonight i think honestly as an mp who
has sat around the cabinet table
we have two incredible candidates both
capable and willing to serve the country
in what will be an incredibly difficult
time as we've heard from tom some of the
statistics lettering the realities that
we know are really hard that are coming
ahead of us and we are going to need a
prime minister
who can stand up and strongly lead us
now i'm here this evening uh backing uh
liz trust i think both fantastic candles
but my voice uh and my bonuses
and i'm gonna tell you why in as short
as i can because i'm getting shouted out
by tom newton an experience that we as
politicians get quite a lot from our
journalist friends uh there are three
reasons i call it lizzy's abc
she's am incredibly ambitious for our
country she is bold in the way she takes
decisions and she is confident in her
energies to give the country what it
needs just to expand on that a little
bit i have watched her uh drive forwards
policies let's take the northern ireland
protocol challenge incredibly difficult
she has been ambitious and determined in
making sure that we hold our unions
together the uk's most important job the
uk government must ensure our union is
secure and liz has taken on that
challenge and driven through the
northern ireland protocol bill to make
sure that our union will be secure
incredibly brave and very very
impressive
she's also
incredibly bold let's be fair who wants
to face defense minister lavrov in
russia and come away in one piece that
is no mean feat not only uh because of
the challenges of being foreign
secretary and having to travel in this
incredibly difficult uh war-torn time
where russia has invaded a sovereign
democratic country but because she has
known and led the charge across the
world to say we must be bold and we must
stand up for democracy we must stand
alongside those who are willing to fight
and watch their sons and daughters die
to defend
she has been incredibly bold she has
taken on detractors across the world and
led the uk charge to do that i am
incredibly proud of her i've sat and
watched her day in day out battle that
one across the world and most
importantly she is incredibly confident
for our country as she puts it she knows
our best days are ahead of us and she
wants to make that happen by giving back
the power in every conservative way
stripping away those regulations uh
handing back more of our money for us to
determine how to spend it she is
absolutely a tory to her boots speaking
as a northern toriel very proud most
northern tory in england that i am i am
incredibly proud to say i would be so
proud to serve with liz uh in a
government led by her i think we have a
really exciting time ahead you have the
most important job and i'm sure all your
friends and neighbors say how come you
get to choose the next prime minister
because that's how the conservative
party constitution works you have an
incredible responsibility and whichever
one of our two candidates selected we
will have a great leader but for my
money it's liz's abc ambitious bold and
confident i look forward to hearing your
votes on the 5th of september thanks
guys
can unleash the potential of all the
people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver
deliver
and deliver for the british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm the candidate with a clear vision
for the future
who can drive change and get
as
things
secretary i negotiated deals with allies
like australia and japan creating
opportunities around the world for
british business and as prime minister i
will continue to deliver on the
opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government to core
conservative principles
low taxes a firm grip on spending
driving growth in the economy and giving
people the opportunity to achieve
anything they want to achieve regardless
of their background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in a government that puts more
money in your pocket and secures a
better life for you and your family
i've consistently delivered when i have
said i will
and i love our country
i want the best for us all
[Music]
please welcome liz truss
hi everybody it's fantastic to be here
tonight in darlington
i remember back in 2017
when ben houchen and simon clark got
elected
and i could see
that we made a crack
in the red wall
but 2019 was a massive demolition job
we got bishop auckland
[Applause]
and we also got to the labour heartland
of sedfield
tony blair's constituency
and as blair himself would say
things can only get better
and if you select me to be your prime
minister
i will work to take new seats in the
northeast
one's back i will work to take
sunderland
and i will work to win the big and i
know we can do it
now i'm not somebody from a traditional
conservative background
i grew up in paisley in scotland and in
leeds
and i went to a comprehensive school
and at that school what i saw
is i saw too many children let down
by low expectations because of their
background
because the lefty lead city council
preferred political correctness to
making sure that children learnt english
and maths
and because of a lack of opportunity in
the area
and i thought that was a huge waste of
talent and opportunity and what i want
for our country
is i want everybody to be able to
succeed regardless of their background
regardless of where they're from
i want people to get on in life and i
want us to be an aspiration nation
but i think we know that we face
difficult economic times
we've got the aftermath of the covert
pandemic
we've got the appalling war being
perpetrated by vladimir putin in ukraine
and i'm afraid to say that over the last
two decades in the uk
we've seen relatively low growth so now
is not the time for business as usual
we need to do things differently
and that's what i would do i would have
a bold plan for growth
first of all
we need to get those eu laws off the
statute books by the end of 2023
that tell government companies what to
do
whether it's our investment rules and we
need to unlock huge swathes of
investment into parts of our country
like the northeast into the steel
industry into the tech industry into the
new giga factory and blind that's what
we need to do
but we also
need to lower taxes
i didn't agree with raising national
insurance we promise not to do it in our
manifesto and we need to help those
people who are struggling with the cost
of living i would also have an immediate
moratorium on the green energy levy to
cut people
and i can promise you i would do that as
prime minister from day one
i'd also keep corporation tax low
because if we raise corporation tax to
the same level it is in france and 10
points higher than ireland we're not
going to attract the grades we're not
going to attract the investment and i'm
afraid to say
our country is more likely to go into a
recession we need to get the economy
growing
and i believe as conservatives we need
to be on the side of small businesses
we need to be on the side of the
self-employed we need to be on the side
of people who work hard and do the right
thing and we need to enable people to
keep more of their own money those are
conservative principles
and i want to make sure that we level up
in a conservative way of course we need
to get the a1 joules
and we need to sort out the broadband
and we need to sort out the mobile phone
signal and we need to make sure that
funding is fair
but we also need to have more investment
and what i would put in place a low tax
enterprise zones i'd deepen our free
ports like our t side freeport and i'd
make sure
that we change our planning system now
before i became an mp
i was a counselor and i sat on a
planning committee
and those are hours of my life i will
never get back
because because we were told what to do
by the planning inspectorate in bristol
or the mandarins in whitehall with their
housing targets
i don't believe in that i believe people
here are best place to make decisions
about their own future
[Applause]
i'm proud that i'm being supported in
this campaign by the former president of
the national farmers union may rig
raymond who i worked with at daphra and
he knows that i'm somebody who wants to
see farmers producing food
not filling in forms not doing red tape
not filling fields with paraphernalia
like solar farms what we want is crops
and we want livestock and i know the
food produced in this part of the
country is fantastic and i want to see
more of it
we are facing a massive issue with food
security and energy security because of
the war in ukraine
and i've been tough in standing up to
russia and standing up to putin
we were the first european country to
send weapons to ukraine
and i put on the toughest package of
sanctions on russia
of any country in the world but we
cannot be complacent
our security is more under threat than
it was we have an increasingly assertive
china too
and what i would do is raise our defense
spending to three percent of gdp by the
end
earlier today earlier today i visited a
defense manufacturer in huddersfield
and it's businesses across
the north of england right across our
country that will benefit from increased
spending on defence
but we also need to defend our borders
and we know that appalling people
traffickers
are
creating
terrible illegal immigration across the
english town
i worked with pretty patel on the rwanda
scheme it is the right scheme but we
need to expand it to more countries and
we also need to legislate to make sure
the british bill of rights cannot be
overruled by the echre
[Applause]
and we've led the free world in back in
ukraine and in fact there is a street in
kiev now named after boris johnson that
is fantastic
but as well as freedom and democracy
overseas we also need it here in britain
and i'm a i'm a straight-talking
yorkshire woman
i know that a woman is a woman
now
i can see people in darlington
understand that but believe me there are
some people in whitehall that don't
and what what i will make sure
is that our single sex spaces are
protected
that domestic violence shelters are
protected and we are standing up for
women's rights
and as foreign secretary i travel around
the world
and i know
that people have huge respect for
britain and what we brought to the world
our values of freedom and democracy and
the rule of law
but unfortunately there are too many
people in britain who don't seem to
agree with that
who seem to think we should be ashamed
of our own country who seem to think
this country is in decline
we will prove those people wrong
we will prove that our best days are
ahead of us and we have huge
opportunities that we can unlock
and as prime minister
i'm somebody who will deliver
now i delivered at the department of
trade i delivered dozens of trade deals
even though people said it couldn't be
done that we couldn't get better deals
in the eu we got better deals and we got
more deals than the eu
and i also made sure that our trade
negotiators were based in the department
of international trade here in
darlington
so that the needs of industry in this
area can be represented in the deals
we're negotiating
at the foreign office i created the new
sanctions regime in record time
and i also put through the northern
ireland protocol bill to restore the
belfast good friday agreement
and lots of people in whitehall didn't
like that it wasn't popular people
didn't want to upset the eu but i got it
done
and i got it into parliament and i got
it through parliament
because
ladies and gentlemen i'm not for
somebody who is prepared to take no for
an answer
i will deliver
what people want us to deliver and i
will deliver it within two years so we
can win the next election and so we can
beat kierstarma who is yet another north
london labour leader who doesn't
understand the people of this country he
doesn't understand aspiration he doesn't
understand why people voted conservative
here in darlington or across the
northeast
and we will deliver we will deliver jobs
will deliver growth and will deliver
opportunities
and we will help people with the cost of
living in crisis and we will help people
earn more and succeed and we will give
people more of their own money so they
can invest in their own future and we
will most of all be proud to be
conservatives because that's why people
voted for us not because they wanted the
labour party but they wanted a strong
conservative government that delivers
for every part of this country and
particularly here in the northeast of
england thank you very much
right folks what i'm for sitting through
what was that an hour or so of speeches
funny your thing they ever ran
who the thought politicians can speak uh
here's the fun part uh we all get to ask
some questions
so
this is how it's gonna work i go first
uh and then it's your turn now a couple
of things if you've got a question have
a look out now for people in white
hoodies um they are around they have
microphones and they'll come to you but
make sure you can see them
and they'll come and find you and the
other rule if your question's already
been asked please don't ask it again
you laugh but you'd be surprised uh
and also uh just keep it to one question
and we'd be very grateful so
without any further ado please welcome
back onto the stage rishi sooner
every poll out there says liz trust is
gonna beat you by a margin of two to one
why are you so far behind well the only
poll that counts is the one at the end
of this thing and we're only just
getting started tom right
you don't want to answer that question
no no i'm out and about all day every
day i'm giving it absolutely everything
i've got and i'm fighting for the things
that i passionately believe in that are
right for this country and i'm just
going to keep doing that with everything
i've got until the last day of this
campaign and i hope i get to see lots of
you over the next few weeks
let's talk about the main story of the
day or quite frankly the main story this
whole contest the cost of increases and
energy bills we had some terrifying new
figures today you've seen some
projections on where energy bills are
going to get to
rising some four thousand four hundred
pounds a year potentially uh next april
they're around one thousand nine hundred
for the ancient family now that that's a
monumental rise now you've announced
today you're gonna use the same
framework in your words used in may as
chancellor direct support grants
payments whatever you want to call them
uh four families in may you spent 15.3
billion pounds helping people pay their
bills are you prepared to say
to spend the same figure again
well i don't i don't think that would be
necessary because what we're talking
about now tom is the extra increase on
top of what we thought and we already
thought bills were going to go up to 3
000 pounds when we announced that
support and
i it's it's really really serious and i
think everyone should be under
absolutely no illusion about how
difficult it's going to be for millions
of families this winter and our
responsibility as a compassionate
conservative government is to make sure
that we support those who most need our
help through that and that's what i did
as chancellor for two years and that's
what i'm going to do as prime minister
and i want to go further than i did
previously because the situation is
worse it's right that we target that on
the people who most need our help and
today i announced what i did because i
wanted to give those people peace of
mind and the only way to help them
is with direct support because tax cuts
alone
are not much good if you're a pensioner
who's not earning any extra money
they're not much good if you're working
hard on the national living wage because
liz's tax cut is worth about a quid a
week for that person it's worth zero for
a pensioner
that's not right that's not a policy
that's going to help people get through
the winter and i i think it's wrong that
she's ruled out direct support to
families because we as a conservative
government have an obligation to help
those who are most vulnerable that is
the only way to do it
believe me i'll have a few questions for
liz as well on this one but i just want
to clarify in may you spent 400 pounds
per household free money rich or poor to
help them pay those bills no matter what
their income that's the sort of thing
you'll do again no because i think what
we need to do is target our support for
the most vulnerable so what i announced
what every house or the manhattan won't
necessarily get free money no because
what i want to do first of all is cut
v80 on energy bills because that's one
of the levers that we have it's a brexit
opportunity which we can deliver and
that provides some support to everybody
but where we need to go further is
particularly for the most vulnerable
households look and we're lucky there'll
be lots of us here in this room tonight
for whom look it's going to be difficult
but it's manageable right or it means
you go without the the luxuries the
extra things in life but there are
millions of families for whom it is
simply not possible no matter how hard
they work to come up with that kind of
cash and that's why our support should
be targeted not on massive tax cuts for
very wealthy people but should be
targeted on helping the people who most
need it and if we don't do that i can
tell you not only will millions of
people suffer we will get absolutely
hammered when it comes to an election
the british people will not forgive us
for not doing that let's talk about
let's talk about how you're going to pay
for this i mean i think we agree we're
in the billions here don't we now you've
come up with efficiency savings now that
to journalists like me means quite
frankly you've got no idea how you but
efficiency savings you can save 5
million 10 million you're not going to
get billions by efficiency savings what
you end up having to do is borrow a lot
more which is precisely what you just
accused was trusted well so no you're
respectfully totally wrong actually
so what did i just do one of my last
things as chancellor because we had to
find some extra money to send to ukraine
right because we wanted to keep
supporting them with their war effort
and i didn't just find 5 million or 10
million from a roundabout government
i found a billion pounds
by efficiencies across government and we
sent that billion pounds to ukraine to
provide to provide support for them so
when you say you can't find efficiency
savings you can only find five or ten i
literally just found a billion and i did
that a couple of months ago so yes i can
find efficiency savings and that's how
we should pay for this in the first
instance which i suppose basic question
why didn't you find more efficiency
savings then but let's not get into a
trap on that well because what we needed
to send them was about a billion pounds
and i found a billion pounds
it's really important that we continue
supporting ukraine in their efforts
against russia i think it's something
that we're probably all very proud of
right
nevertheless your critics say vast state
handouts spent on propping up a failing
economy is not exactly a very tory thing
to do in fact the accused have been
gordon brown two-point lord well i tell
you
i tell you what is a conservative thing
to do conservatism is about being
pragmatic right that has long been a
tenant of our party and we've got to
take the world as it is not how we would
like it to be right so if we've got a
situation where millions of pensioners
for example are going to see increases
in their bills of a thousand pounds
right they're not in work
this is a tax cut or any tax cut it's
not going to help them
so how else
do you propose that a conservative
government that wants to support some of
those vulnerable pensioners does it
now i i think it's an entirely
conservative thing to give people
dignity in retirement i think it's an
entirely conservative thing to support
the most vulnerable pensioners and
that's what i'm going to do
now the director general of the cbi tony
danker a man who you will know has
joined i have to say very loud calls
across government across party lines
today to ask you liz trust and boris
johnson to get together in a room and
decide exactly what this targeted help
should be for people not on the 6th of
september right now because you just
simply don't have four weeks to spare
are you prepared to do that but
of course i'm happy to do that but as
you can see we're in the midst of uh a
leadership contest where the answer to
that very question is at stake
right because it's all about that you
are prepared to do that you'd like to do
that i'm looking at our party chairman
i'm not sure how we'd feel about
curtailing this process
we're actually having this debate
because it's an important debate to have
because you're going to hear one point
of view from me about how i think we
need to do it this autumn winter i
believe it is the only way to do this to
actually help the people who need our
help and then in 15 minutes time you're
going to hear a completely different
approach right and the question is if
you only want to help these people with
tax cuts
i i'm struggling to see how it's
possible so we can get in a room all you
want but at the end of the day
that policy is not going to work so if
you can get liz to change her mind on
that when she talks to you i'm very
happy to get in the room and we can
hammer this out
okay
let's
let's see what uh liz says and see if we
can have some peace both under this i
suspect you're probably right
let's move on though we're in the red
wall here as well you know uh
darlington's labor seat for 27 years
before 2019. how are you going to repeat
your predecessor's feet boris johnson's
feet of winning 55 seats across the red
wall because as your critics say you'll
know boris johnson yeah well look you
know for better or worse none of us are
boris johnson right i think we'd be
clear about that right and um so look i
you know i'm really privileged to have
the support of ben hampton right and if
you if you think back to ben's first
election and his second election and all
the change that's happened in our area
over the last several years which i
talked about in my speech right that has
been something that has been the product
of an enormous amount of people's hard
work and effort and i am confident that
i can continue to do that and that's why
ben is supporting me because he knows
that i deliver for the people of the red
wall and i deliver not just practical
things like the treasury or free ports
or investment in high streets and town
centres and spreading opportunity it's
because my values are the same values as
the people that we all live and work
amongst the people that we represent
it's those values of hard work a family
of fairness and aspiration it's not
about blue wall or red bull those are
british values and they're conservative
values they're my values and that's how
we're going to win all these seats all
right let me
i want to ask you uh about you
personally now because it was noted in
the sunday times this weekend darris
says leaning newspaper that you and your
wife are personally richer
than the queen
now what do you say to people who say to
you how on earth do you have any idea
what life is like a tough life is like
for us yeah so
that you're probably about the tenth
person who's asked me this question tom
right on this leadership trail and you
know i think in our country we judge
people not by their bank account we
judge them by their character and their
actions right
and yes i'm i'm really fortunate to be
in the situation
now but i wasn't born like this right i
wasn't i
my parents worked really hard to provide
me with all these opportunities i'm not
going to apologize for what they did for
me and in fact that's why i want to do
this job because i want to provide those
opportunities for everyone else that's
what conservative governments do
a little bit of quick fire just to get
some sort of pretty straightforward
answers now because we're coming to the
end of my turn as soon as uh the
audience's turn uh state spending is
pretty popular in uh parts of the north
perhaps more popular than parts of the
south i wanted to ask you
public services are going to be hit
really hard by inflation 13
hits the nhs and schools just as much as
it does individuals so are you prepared
to keep nhs spending real terms where it
is now
the nhs spending is is fine where it is
and what we need out of the nhs is more
reform more efficiency that's what i'm
going to do
the important question here is you're
going to have to spend 30 more on the
nhs to keep it the same budget real
terms now i think you just said you're
prepared to do that no no i'm not
prepared to do that number is also not
right but in any case
i did something very difficult this is
the quick fire but well well this is a
really important question because it's
the most important public service right
and it's a thing that everyone does rely
on and it's not working as well as it
should right now right now i did
something difficult which was getting
some more funding into both the nhs and
social care which for too long has been
the poor cousin of the nhs we need to
fix that but we're conservatives in this
room it's not just about putting the
money in i did do that because it was
the right thing to do whether it was
popular or not as a separate thing
but now we've got to move on to
reforming and getting the efficiency out
of it now i've got a bold plan to do
that i'm sure we'll talk about it in the
q a but it means being radical it means
being tough on the things that we were
too scared to confront like missed
appointments which i want to clamp down
on but that's what we're going to do to
get better performance out of the nhs
that's what conservative governments
deliver and that's what we need to do if
we're going to get people's taxes down
okay
okay now the real quick starts this this
should be a bit easier for you should
the parliamentary inquiry to whether
boris johnson misled parliament continue
yeah i mean
i mean absolutely the mps who are on
that panel will make the right decisions
for them
right the privileged committee should
make all those right decisions that's
why we have a parliamentary sort of
government decision and there's an
important distinction right because
parliament is its own entity there are
independent mps who are on there who
will make all the right decisions but
look as a general question i think trust
and integrity and decency and politics
is really important and as prime
minister that's what i want to bring
back to government
this is really straightforward is boris
johnson's downfall his own thoughts on
someone else's his own okay there's
quickfires
[Applause]
we're going to wrap it through these
folks so you get lots of time as well
powerhouse northern powerhouse rail
which is the high speed link between
liverpool manchester and leeds the
government recently said it's going to
not do it would you reinstate it and do
it no that's that's not right the
government actually said it was going to
spend 96 billion pounds over the next
several years
high speed link from east to west
yes actually improved connectivity
across east west believe me i know i
travel from north allen to manchester
and it is a nightmare right and it's far
easier to get to london and we will fix
it right we're going to fix it and we're
going to get that journey time down to a
half an hour between leeds and
manchester we're going to connect up all
the towns and cities of the north i was
proud to do that as chancellor and as a
conservative government for the first
time people are recognizing gosh these
guys are investing in the north they get
it and as prime minister i'm going to
carry on doing exactly that you won't
change the current government plan today
no okay if you lose this contest and
you're invited to serve in a liz trust
cabinet will you yes in any job yes
okay that's
great it going it was a quick fire thank
you
it's not it's not it's not the first
time these questions have been asked
right
it might be the first time this audience
has heard that
finally i'm going to ask this of liz
trust too then it's the audience's turn
your predecessor's personal failings is
one of the main reasons why we're here
is there anything you've done in your
past life that could one day embarrass
your government
or
is every prime minister entitled to a
past
oh gosh well i mean everyone has a past
right i mean i think mine everyone knows
about i've been in a serious significant
job in the public eye for the last two
years so and the most embarrassing thing
that's happened to me is i you know
struggled to pay for the petrol in a car
that wasn't my own right so i think you
all know about that right and and since
then someone's taught me how to use that
contactless machine and i tell you it's
a really it's an amazing modern marvel
this technology these days
some debate about whether that car was
really yours as well but i said it was
good yeah no no it's even doubly
embarrassing right okay
audience's turn please put up your hands
if you have a question for mr sumner
should we go straight here
[Music]
right yeah
uh whichever you'd like to do sir
hi richie hi my name's alan alan yeah
nice to see you right
um something bugged me for the last
three weeks about something you said and
i want to read it out to you and see if
you stand by it whether you want to
slightly alter it
or
we'll see
as soon as you were elected to be one of
the two candidates you came out and said
these words
i believe i am the only candidate that
is capable of beating kirstalma
do you stand by that
just give us a proper answer please do
you stand by that this is what you said
you said it a few times and that's
bugged me so i want to know and the
other thing was can you remember i don't
know shakespeare or hesseltine said he
who wields the dagger will never inherit
the crown
right okay so let's just do both of them
right
so
it's all right that's right that's right
you're fully entitled to ask questions
sir
and asks question right so yeah you're
asking why i resigned yes it was really
sad i was sad i had to resign actually i
was sad i was like but actually
you are totally and i respectfully you
are simply wrong to say that i wielded
the dagger because because you know what
it wasn't just me who felt that enough
was enough the government was on the
wrong side of yet another ethical
decision
it was 660 other 60 other members of
parliament also thought that enough was
enough because we wanted to change
things and that's why we're here and yes
the simple answer to that question is
yes i am the person who can beat kirst
armour that's why i'm standing here
today
okay
let's go to
the lady in the red dress holding her
hand up just on the end here
oh actually they're leaning on but why
don't you go now
my name is michelle and i would like to
ask you about the a1 um a lot of people
ask us about getting a dual carriageway
and i know that liz had mentioned that
and what would be your plans around that
making the road network better for the
northeast yes so look i know it's
something that's really important it's
something we put in our manifesto and
it's something as chancellor i in theory
signed off on the funding for but i know
recently there's been some issue and the
transport secretary is having another
look at those plans i'm not sure what
the issue is but as prime minister i can
certainly commit to you that i will go
and figure out quickly what the
situation is because i would like to see
the a1 dueled i travel on it a lot i
travel on the a19 not only do we need to
do that we need to figure out the t's
crossing as well and those are the types
of investments that will make a real
difference to connectivity in the north
and you have my absolute insurance as a
matter of urgency i will go and find out
why that thing has been slowed down and
get it back on track
[Applause]
hello
i'm a 70 year old pensioner
and
one thing that's upset me is i was born
in 1952
you changed all the pension rates for
1950 if you're born 53 and after
i actually receive i've paid all my
stamps
and
i received less money every month than
someone who is born
from 53 onwards i don't think that's
right
i think
all pensioners have got the same cost of
living and if you've paid all your
stamps why should that be different
right well
man are you are you talking about the
the waspy situation as it's called or
something different
because
just the fact that
when they
changed it
if it's the waspy situation all i could
say is look that's a process which i
know has been really difficult for
millions of of women it's been through
various arbitrations
okay in which case i'm happy to go away
and take a look at that because i'm not
familiar with the specific issue that
you're talking about but if you email me
i'll i'll happily go and take a look
let's go to the left side of the room
here uh that's no intention on the
candidate with the t-shirt we're uh
ready for rishi uh please don't have a
microphone to lady and they're ready for
rishi t-shirt thanks
my name is jill i'm very passionate
about climate change and i'm very proud
of the fact that
the uk is a leader in offshore wind and
it's very important to the north east
i just wanted to ask one question in
terms of your um attitude to climate
change in terms of not going back on our
current climate pledges and what else
will you do
to encourage innovation
in climate technology yes well thank you
jill and
my my two young girls who are nine and
11 who are probably were allowed i don't
know if we are let's say they could stay
up late tonight to watch this or not but
in any case um the only thing they ever
ask me about my job is this right they
say daddy what are you doing for the
environment the rest of it is is largely
irrelevant to them and you you mentioned
the great word it's innovation right the
way we're going to solve this problem is
not by getting people to give up all the
things that they love it's not by saying
endlessly their bills have to go up it's
by making sure that we here in the uk
create the new technologies of the
future they're going to provide cheaper
renewable reliable energy for us and the
great news is it's happening right here
in the northeast right it's happening in
t side with hydrogen with carbon capture
and storage and with offshore wind with
ge's investment right here creating jobs
and the new key that's being developed
that i helped improve so that we can
start exporting things around the world
as well so that's how we're going to
solve the problem i am completely
committed to all those things but we're
going to do it in a way that is pro
innovation because that's how we're
going to bring everyone along with us on
this journey by demonstrating that we
can create jobs and prosperity in places
like this and meet our climate
objectives and keep my two daughters
very happy at night so thank you very
much
we go to the gentleman with his hand
raised wearing a white shirt gray hair
glasses that's the gentleman just needs
a microphone
also sitting on the left but again no
reflection as politics yeah hi michelle
my name is kevin i grew up in the center
of stockton aunties
alongside tony raider from the
conservatives
i've just got a very and i'm glad you're
pragmatic because i'm a very pragmatic
guy yeah
can somebody please explain to me what
leveling up means
and i don't want a political answer
i want a practical
man-to-man answer yeah
because
i don't i do not understand it
you think you didn't say person to
person yeah it wouldn't have gone down
well with this crap right so look for me
it's very simple the one sentence answer
for me when i'm asked is that i want
everyone no matter where they live in
the uk to feel that they have fantastic
opportunities
and that they have pride in the place
they call home so that's what it's about
it's about opportunity and pride in your
home what does it mean here well we're
delivering the opportunities with things
like the freeport right which is
attracting jobs and investment that's an
example of leveling up but we're also
wanting to make sure people have pride
in the places they call home that's what
we're investing in the high streets and
town centers
in eagles cliff in yarm in stockton in
thornaby in hartlepool so that people
when they walk around feel fantastic
about the place that they live and feel
that it is not neglected so if we can do
that everywhere if we can make sure
people feel that there's opportunity for
them and pride in their home we are
going to have leveled up that's what
we're doing here and that's what we need
to do across the united kingdom all
right i'm going to break i'm going to
break the golden rule here
hold on to that microphone i want a
question for you now at the same time we
asked that question are you happy with
that answer yes or no do you understand
living up now no i don't understand it i
just i just wanna because he's a numbers
guy i play with numbers also
i grew up right in the center of
stockton yeah just on the news the other
day with the highest knife crime in the
country we have the highest deprivation
in the country you then come in sir no
disrespect and you spend 600 billion
outside
of stockton and yet our crime is just
the town centers where i grew up
i mean we didn't have a lot of money
like ourselves we were quite poor but
what we had was clean
it's no longer clean
and and no disrespect again you're
spending 600 billion i'm an engineer
worked all over the world and all the
big plants
know how they work
you're spending 600 billion for plants
that will run at 99 to 100 percent
efficient
won't give work to the people that need
it
that need it in the center of school
right
now no because when i talk about pride
in the place you call home it's of
course it's about security and safety
well i talked about in my speech i want
our kids i want my two girls to be able
to walk around stop them when they're a
bit older and feel safe when they go to
the cinema there right so that is about
pride in your home yes it's about a town
centre that looks and feels great but
it's about something that looks clean
something that's safe that's why putting
more police officers on the street
that's why we're tackling county lines
in places like this because we need to
if we're going to stop drug crime and
knife crime it's neat why we need to be
tough on stopping and searching people
we need to not let get not let political
correctness get in the way of actually
tackling some of these crimes that's
what i'm gonna do
okay
we're going to go to the more expensive
seats now in the dress circle uh why
don't we take uh the lady who's been
very patient with her hand up down here
on uh the left lady wearing a it looks
like a red dress from here microphone
coming to that's you thank you exactly
microphone coming to you in three
seconds
okay very quick question
so
it is about crime and it's about the
fact that um i feel very aggrieved that
the word recreational drug exists
i would like that to be something high
on the priority for the future that it
is not acceptable and that families who
are actually
suffering as a result of
a group of people who find that
recreational drug taking is a
pleasurable pastime at their expense
where young children have been stabbed
and there's counter lines problems so
that's one of the big issues that i have
thank you yeah no you're right
i i'm with you right i approach these
questions first and foremost as a parent
and drugs are horrific and they ruin
people's lives there is nothing
recreational about them right i have
never taken them and i will be
incredibly tough on anyone who does and
those who supply them right because look
i want my girls to grow up in a safe
environment right i want to make sure
that they are not at risk of those
things they're not a risk of people
peddling things for them that are going
to ruin their lives and i talked about
it before there's another crime actually
that while you mentioned it i really
want to tackle and it's a crime that
does not get talked about enough in our
country and that's because it's awkward
but as a father of two girls it needs to
and that is the issue of grooming gowns
because for too long
for too long
we have not addressed that
now
these crimes are pernicious they are
horrific and i want to make sure we have
dedicated police units looking at them i
want to make sure we actually record the
ethnicity of the people doing them that
we don't do today
right i want to have a new life sentence
with no parole for the people that are
involved because as i said before no
conservative government that i lead will
let political correctness stand in the
way of taking down these people because
what they do is horrific and we must
stop it
the middle there waving is arm now
red t-shirt or not sorry on the
left-hand side in the in the white shirt
put it behind that's him that's it
yeah good evening my name's jonty um i'm
just uh wondering why the government or
or you haven't considered if you want to
make a immediate impact in people's
pockets reducing the double taxation on
on fuel that people pay at the pump
especially in rural communities where
people are so reliant on their cars and
obviously the cost of distribution would
then be uh you know would be reduced and
help to bring inflation down on pricing
yeah look sir you're right and
particularly i represent you know my
north yorkshire uh friends who are all
here tonight i represent one of those
rural parts of the country so i know how
difficult it is with fuel bills where
they are and that's why as chancellor i
did cut fuel duty by the biggest amount
that it's ever been cut but you know
what it's not as if any of you are
feeling that at the pumps are you right
because the way that market works the
way oil prices are that dwarfs what is
going on now with what's going on the
taxes so the better way to provide help
to the people we need to as i was
talking about earlier is getting direct
support to those who are most vulnerable
and then that can then help them with
all the bills that they face and that's
what we're going to do right so not only
are we going to cut vat on energy bills
because that does go directly and we're
in control of that and help those people
but we're also going to get support to
those who need it and look if if cutting
fuel duty makes sense in the future of
course i'd look at it i just did it
right i just did it a few months ago but
the problem is as you all know is it
working it's not obvious that it is
making an enormous difference and that's
why we've got to focus on the things
that work not the things that just sound
good right because ultimately i want to
help people and i'm going to figure out
the best way to do that and those in
rural areas as you say
always need to make sure that we look
after them because their heating
situation is completely different and
that's why all the interventions i did
as chancellor acknowledge the fact that
lots of people are off the gas grid
right and i wanted to make sure that
support still came to them because i get
that at home every week and i know that
and when it comes to increasing the
energy efficiency of people's homes i
want to focus on those in rural areas
because their homes are the ones that
are least well insulated and the
government can help do that and that's
gonna save people three four five
hundred pounds a year if we step in and
do that that's a type of policy that
won't just help this winter it will help
every winter for years to come and
that's what i'm going to try and do as
prime minister
okay we've got time for one more
question
uh i think it's going to go to the lucky
man in the red t-shirt that mr sooner
likes so much a minute back uh if you
can pass the microphone to the man with
his arm up now
sir
hello i'm jeremy um
as a small business owner one thing that
cripples a lot of businesses is business
rates what would you do to help support
small independent businesses yeah so
you're right and particularly about your
business but particularly those
businesses in the hospitality and the
retail sector right those on our high
streets and our town centres that is the
number one tax that they talked to me
about when i was chancellor that's why
i'm the pandemic i did an enormous
amount to help support that industry
because i know how important it is to
our communities the jobs that it
provides it's why this year i cut
business rates for those businesses by
50
as chancellor that's the biggest tax cut
on business rates outside of chronovirus
we've ever seen in this country because
i know that is the number one thing that
makes a difference this autumn in the
budget we will do the same right and
that's what i've said because the tax
cut we've put in places just for this
year and in the autumn we will need to
set and place the business rates for the
next few years and the top of my mind is
always going to be supporting our high
streets and town centres because they
are their beating hearts of all our
communities all our market towns all our
villages everything they need our
support it's a conservative thing to do
to make sure our communities are strong
the best way to help them is through
business rates that's what i did as
chancellor and that's what i'll do as
prime minister
um
so
uh a small interlude folks while that
one microphone gets uh swapped back over
what have you spent all your money on i
don't really understand you know my
microphone if you if you were
um interesting the uh
i won't repeat that um there's a lot of
rishi t-shirts a lot of rishi placards
just out of my own interest where's all
the there's a trust t-shirt there's some
trust people they're there they're
everywhere they're popping up
good uh in which case with no further
ado here is liz truss
uh there's welcome stage
let's get straight to the big story of
the day i think it's a big story of the
entire contest the cost of living and
those energy bills now rishi sugar has
just told me he's prepared to match the
sort of generosity he showed in may uh
with direct support govern money
straight to people's bank accounts to
help them pay bills to the tune of
billions come the autumn will you do the
same thing
what i want to do
is make sure first of all we're reducing
taxes
because that is needed to drive economic
growth
currently the country is predicted to go
into a recession that will be a huge
problem we know what recessions are like
people lose their jobs there are fewer
opportunities
wages are lower and we need to avoid
that
and at the moment we have the highest
taxes in 70 years so what i would do is
immediately reverse the national
insurance rise i'd also have a temporary
moratorium on the green energy levy to
save people money on fuel bills i do
that from day one but also what i would
do is keep corporation tax low because
we cannot tax our way to growth and i
believe in conservative economics i
believe in a growing economy and a
growing economy actually brings in more
tax revenue in the future so that's a
really fundamental principle for me now
we are facing great difficulties with
energy and i understand people are
struggling with their bills on fuel and
food but the first thing we should do as
conservatives is help people have more
of their own money what i don't support
is taking people
taking money off people in tax and then
giving it back to them in handouts that
to me is gordon brown economics
and what we got was a slow growth
economy and we didn't get the
opportunities we didn't get the
enterprises we didn't get the new jobs
in places like darlington which is one
of the reasons people voted conservative
they voted conservative because they
want to see enterprise they want to see
new opportunities and that is why it's
so important that we don't raise taxes
that we keep taxes low and also we
abolish these eu rules that are holding
back investments into our country
gordon brown economics you're accusing
rishi sunak of having gordon brown
economics what i'm saying is that
well
if i was actually responding to your
question tom
which is what i'm here for which is what
i'm hearing
which is
which is you know do you just
do you just think about there's a fixed
pie we have to share out the pie and we
have to give out money in handouts my
view is we can grow the pie that there
is a having lower taxes actually helps
us generate more income into the economy
so there is more money to go round and
what i fundamentally don't agree with is
putting up taxes and then also giving
out benefits i think that's the wrong
approach okay
now here's the thing with tax cuts and
you know these numbers as well what
you're proposing that the knicks cut or
stopping the rise uh again uh saves
people about 170 pounds a year uh
stopping the green levees under 53
pounds a year as a total of 323 pounds a
year now energy bills according to
today's predictions are going up to four
thousand four hundred pounds a year next
april they're currently at one thousand
nine hundred that's where the price gap
is so with your giveaways
without your handouts you just put it
you're leaving so wait for the question
liz
this is the problem with the way that
every question is great well
excuse me for framing the question right
away but can i just ruin this
tom i'm afraid the whole media does this
all the time
we're all left with stooges and you're
trying to count down the clock let me
put the question to you you're leaving
with your tax cuts people some two
thousand pounds out of pocket i ask you
again are you prepared to help them with
government money call them grants call
them support call them handouts at any
stage in your premiership for them to
pay those energy bills well i think the
important word in your sentence was
today
that is the prediction today this
leadership election is about who is
going to be the prime minister in
september and what's important is the
prime minister at the time and the
chancellor looks at the situation
and of course my first priority is
reducing taxes i think it's important
people keep more of their own money and
it's important we grow the economy and
we avoid recession
my second priority
is dealing with the supply issue and the
number one thing we can do to end this
energy crisis is to stand up to vladimir
putin in ukraine because that is what is
causing the global price spike and that
is why it's so important we are
investing in defence and we're doing all
we can to stop vladimir putin
and i also want to make sure we're
exploiting all of the gas reserves
and the capacity we have in the uk so we
should be fracking this is important tom
because
but it is important we increase the
supply of energy and there are more
resources to be used in the north sea
there is more we can do on nuclear and
there's more we can do on fracking we
should do all of those things
but of course in any budget the
chancellor has to look at the situation
people are facing across the country and
that decision
handouts am i right i'm not i'm not
going to say
in the middle of august what is going to
be in a budget later this year but what
i am saying philosophically
is i always favor people keeping more of
their own money first and what i think
is completely wrong is the idea that we
take huge sways of people's money
hard-working people and then give it
back to them and then then claim it's a
giveaway and it's our money that is
completely wrong
okay
for record he didn't rule out handouts i
wonder if it was a handout when rishi
did it in may that 15 billion but i
think we've done enough on handouts as
you call them the cbi address general
tony danker i put this question to rishi
soon like a minute back uh he wants you
rishi sunak and boris johnson to get
into a room agree a policy right now to
help people pay those bills not on the
6th of september when you get into
office on the 21st of september which
apparently when your emergency budget is
going to be right now would you agree
and do you want to get into that room
with rishi boris tomorrow
well first of all i am foreign secretary
and i'm focusing my energy on dealing
with the very serious foreign policy
issues we face
the issues in taiwan
uh the issues with russia and ukraine
and that is rightly my focus we have a
chancellor nadam zahawi we have a prime
minister who are in those jobs until
september and i think it would be
constitutionally deeply undesirable to
try and overrule them with a sort of
made-up committee of the cbi me and
rishi zunak which is
not just because he's a supporter of my
campaign and he is um is a fantastic
chat
boris johnson has done a great job as
prime minister delivering brexit
delivering
delivering on the covered vaccine
standing up to putin they are capable
people capable of making these decisions
this kangaroo committee you're proposing
sounds bizarre okay
it was
tony danke and gordon brown proposing it
not me for the record list
sorry we're going to go into boarding
around again let me ask you about uh
something quite serious again something
i put to mississippi i'm really
interested in your views on state
spending is not immune to inflation
inflation could pass 13 quite soon that
means government budgets are going to
need a lot more money spent on them are
you prepared to keep the nh project
where it is now in real terms in other
words spend quite a bit more money
keeping spending in real terms where it
is now well just to be clear i am
committed to the additional spending on
the nhs the 13 billion i want more of it
to go into social care i want more of it
to go directly to councils which is what
questions well it is answering the
question because that is the nhs budget
and i do think the nhs budget will have
to continue to go up
in real terms but i'm not
going to pre-judge the spending review
which i want to be committed alongside
the budget all right let me ask you
something that's been rumored uh is it
true your team are in open access talks
already with a cabinet office about what
your premise should look like
no that's not true okay thank you for
clearing that one up i want to ask you
about your character and judgment a
little bit because
what you say to people uh who look at
your record and they say to you
she was a remainer and then she wrote
that up
first she advocated bristol to ukraine
and fight then she cancelled that
then she advocated regional pay and that
got canned in about uh 16 hours and then
you're saying you're not going to do
handouts you don't actually deny to me
that you are going to do handouts they
say to you your judgment is all over the
place and it stinks
well on the subject of brexit
i did support remain i was
you know pretty much on the fence
beforehand but i decided to back remain
i was loyal to avid cameron but the
minute
that vote came through i put my
shoulders to the wheel and i think i've
done more than most people in the
government to deliver on the benefits of
brexit whether it's the
trade deals whether it's
the toughest sanctions regime and look
in politics you have to be prepared to
you know deal with the situation you
face and somebody who refuses to change
their mind in the face of all the
evidence that i'd point to the national
insurance rise as a case in point even
though people are struggling
that is a problem and i'm somebody who
is decisive
i have very clear principles i've
outlined them i want people to keep more
of their own money i want us to be a
late tax high growth country but of
course i'm prepared to consider the
evidence and make decisions and when
when there is a problem
i'm somebody who acts quickly and
decisively to deal with the problem and
i'm honest about it what you see with me
is what you get you know i'm not i'm not
the slickest i'm not claiming to be the
slickest but i am somebody and people
who work with me in government and i'm
backed by a lot of my colleagues in the
cabinet and i'm backed by a lot of
colleagues who've worked with me because
they know i work hard i deliver i'm
determined and i don't take no for an
answer all right
i'd like to get to uh some point fire uh
now listen i struggle with rishi because
quickfire turned to be long fired but
let's see if we can do this quickly
because if you don't you're just
depriving the wonderful audience of
their term to ask questions should the
parliamentary inquiry into whether boris
johnson miss led parliament continue
well that's a matter for parliament but
i personally don't believe he misled
parliament well you're an mp
therefore what is the point of the
committee
if you had a vote would you vote
well yes but there isn't a vote and it's
going ahead all right
are you clear boris johnson's downfall
was it his own making or someone else's
it sounds like you're being blamed tom
and you know who who am i to disagree
with this excellent audience
[Applause]
was the media's fault that's your real
view is it
not the audience's view not the odyssey
that's your view
as i said i was one of boris's first
backers i was his first cabinet backer i
was a loyal cabinet minister
i continue to serve as foreign secretary
because i believe it's a very important
job and i would be wrong to leave my
post but what what is done i mean you
know what it's done is done and we are
where we are you avoided uh getting into
the literacy of that one next quickfire
would you follow through on nadine
doris's peerage if that's what the
outgoing prime minister aloud
we're not answering questions about
hypotheticals tom okay that i'll put you
on the fence on that one then still
here's an easier one will you reinstate
northern powerhouse rail which the
government
yes and it will go to bradford as well i
can tell you
okay it's another big spending
commitment you put that one on the never
never as well
tom what i am about is making sure the
economy grows by unleashing enterprise
and opportunity keeping taxes low
getting rid of those eu laws that are
holding our country back and that's what
i would do i believe in britain unlike
some of the media who choose to talk our
country
that's the third time you've attacked
the media a lot of which supports your
campaign but anyway we can talk about
that one later maybe here's an easy one
for you
are you looking forward to a second
donald trump presidency
[Music]
i think it's pretty unwise to comment on
elections in other countries
particularly when you're
like to see him foreign
i'll just say it's very unwise to
comment on elections in other countries
all right uh the one thing you've been
drawn on that one the one thing you've
done asked me the easier yes or no
question i'll answer it so this is
really easy one what's the one thing
you've done in government you most
regret
um
it's hard to come up with one to be
honest
we've got time haven't we well i i do
hugely regret that the government went
ahead with the national insurance rise
against
against uh
against what was in our manifesto and i
spoke out against it at the time
if you
lose this campaign and rishi sunny asks
you to serve in a sunnah cabinet will
you
that what what i care about is our
country and i'm prepared to do whatever
job
to serve our country is required of me
what i don't understand is that richard
said he'd serve in your cabinet as well
you have diametrically opposed views on
the economy how to get us out of the
trouble we're in and how to help people
pay bills how on earth can you two go on
the radio or the television or indeed
talk tv and defend each other's economic
policies
well
i might have differences with rishi
sinak but i prefer him to secure stammer
all right final question i'll ask this
of rishi sunak too your predecessor's
personal failings is one of the reasons
why we're all here
is there anything you've done in your
past life that could one day come back
to embarrass the government that you
lead or is every prime minister entitled
to a private life well i i have no
skeletons in my closet tom i think
everything there is to be known about me
is known about me and you've mentioned a
lot of it already in this interview
we could go for longer but
that's the name well what was the first
question there are no skeletons in my
closet there is nothing that is not
known about me it's a public domain okay
let's open this up to the audience and
if you'd like to go to we'll start in
what on the cheap seats but down there
first
should we go to the gentleman in the
middle there with the black t-shirt and
the black jacket
uh with a microphone coming to you now
sir
hello hello liz hello my name is taryn
and i was wondering
if you were capable of being able to
muster a compliment about your opponent
richie sunax campaign
well well he's got a very nice t-shirt
which i see you're wearing
thank you
let's have a question from uh further
back in the stalls if we can get the
microphone up there how about the
gentleman who appears to have a well
you've all got blue wristbands on us we
have white shirts very high hands uh
dark hair lifting from your seat now
that gentleman there you can pass
microphone to
that gentleman thank you
thank you very much my name is richard
uh liz like yourself a border bred
yorkshire person man woman and uh
thank you man
uh very much slightly self conservative
from a conservative pedigree that i am a
proud conservative voter came from a
working-class background went to a
comprehensive school
saw an opportunity to join the british
army served my country for 26 years
retired thank you
this is not about me this is about liz
and subsequently done very well uh as a
veteran and uh my question is
about benefits a strange question
but not all benefits are means tested
which means that in certain households
where you've got children
some some earners
are now
in a in a sort of situation where
they're earning above the child benefit
threshold
but the means salary for that household
could potentially result with two
earners earning potentially 35 40 000
pounds a year
significantly more than what i earned
but yet that family is still entitled to
child benefits so can we address how
benefits are
applied to to working families because i
work hard and i've worked hard all of my
life but i've recently got a pair eyes
and i actually learn less yeah because
child benefits being took away from me
the one i earned before i got my per
hour because i work hard and that for me
is conservatism right we work hard we
roll the sleeves up we see strike and
grasp those opportunities and for me
that's a real key focus because when
everyone got their 400 pound payment for
energy well donaldson towns have to
never look so busy because they're all
in town celebrating drinking beer and
eat you know
whereas people like me who aren't
entitled to those type of payments
first of all
first of all thank you for your service
to our country
and
one thing i will do is make sure we have
a veterans minister
in the cabinet making sure we support
i do think
our tax system in particular is too
complicated and i will have an overall
review of the tax system to look at how
it can work better i think there are
problems with business rates uh there
are problems with uh the way it works
for the self-employed but there are
particular problems with families
and the way that you know we we don't
have a very pro-family tax system i want
to make it easier for families where
people take time out of work either to
look after children or to look after
elderly relatives and you're absolutely
right about the way that the child
benefit suddenly cuts off so i will look
at that in in in the round
to make the system
more pro family but also simpler for
people too
okay let's talk to the lady with the uh
silver hair rather than the gray hair
with that arm raised what looks like a
green
it's blonde
you know you just can't trust the media
can you this is the theme tonight
my apologies
i am an nhs nurse i've worked in the nhs
for 30 years
i retired
in 2021 came back
to work as a covert vaccinator
out of retirement
i'm also a waspy woman so i'm still not
getting the state benefit
but my question about the nhs is
um
if you could give me a flavor of how
you
see it needs reforming and i don't mean
just charging 10 pounds for missed
appointments
i mean how will you change the group
think
of nhs management
thanks very much and um
my mum was a nurse working in the
national health service in fact in leeds
at st james's hospital so i heard a lot
of stories about how things were or
or weren't working when i was at home
and
what i would say is we need to make sure
that
we are
retaining the really important staff on
the front line our nurses and doctors
and i hear too many
stories about how there are lots of
layers of management
in the organization there are a lot of
central dictats
that people aren't able to make
decisions
about what's best for patients
and i think we need more
more local decision making
i i think we need to
you know people like you who did a
fantastic job coming back into the
national health service during covert i
wonder what more we could encourage
people to come back to help now that we
face you know issues with waiting lists
issues with people not being able to get
gep appointments but fundamentally for
me
the issue does seem to be about
excessive bureaucracy excessive central
direction and too many layers of
management
rather than allowing people on the front
line to make the decision
it's a really important point about the
job of prime ministers the prime
minister cannot run
every single department in the cabinet
and what i am somebody who does is i
trust other people to
run things and i would make sure
if selected as prime minister i appoint
a really good health secretary who can
get on with the job he can be trusted to
deliver
and will deliver those changes we need
to see on the front line because as you
say you know there are real issues and i
also want to look at the issue of gp's
pensions because we know many gps are
leaving the profession because of the
perverse issues around their pensions so
you're going to have a job to rishi
sooner it's been rumored
look i haven't you know i'm not getting
ahead of myself i'm not thinking about
that at the moment but i i can assure
you that it's an absolute priority and
you're going around the country and
hearing from people there are there were
real issues there on the front line can
we get the microphone to the gentleman
in the blue jacket uh in the middle
please he's been extremely patient has
hannah for a long time
hi there and my question to you liz is
0.7 of gdp golden foreign aid what will
you do to get it back up to that because
that was achieved under your tenure as a
national development secretary and you
know we're talking now about heating
homes fuel costs and what have you go to
africa they've got
no homes to eat well i mean they don't
eat heating but you get the juice
they've got no cars to fend
they've got no cars to fill with fuel in
fact they barely have dirt roads and the
only water source i've got is colour
infested ponds 15 miles away from the
home so what will you do to get us back
up to that target because it's very
important to people living poverty
across the world
well thank you i mean what i've done at
the foreign office which is now got the
international development budget as part
of it
is i've made sure
that we're sending less money
to multilateral organizations like the
world bank and instead we're spending
more money on humanitarian aid
particularly helping people with the
very severe issues in the horn of africa
helping people in ukraine
after the appalling war
has left so many people without homes
without food so what what i have done is
made sure that we're using the existing
budget to really focus on the priority
humanitarian issues rather than funding
these big multilateral organizations
okay
microphone
down here please to another patient
waiting a long time with a hand up in
the black top
that lady just said sunglasses on her
head
you previously stated that you believe
that a woman is a woman
is there no circumstances in which you
would regard a man as a woman or vice
versa
well
you know i believe everybody should be
treated with respect in our society
including transgender people but what
what i do believe is that biological sex
is important
and it is important for making sure
that you know we protect domestic
violence shelters that we protect single
sex spaces
women's rights have been hard fought for
for generations and what i am concerned
about is for example in sport you know
unequal treatment in sports so i am very
clear that biological sex is important
and that's what should guide those very
sensitive areas of
a man can be policy woman legally at the
moment certified by two doctors would
you want to change that
well
you can be a different gender
and that is fine you can live in the
other gender
if you if you say wish and i completely
respect that that is not the same as
biological sex
and where there are sensitive issues
like domestic violence shelters i you
know you were perfectly entitled under
the equality act to separate people on
the basis of biological sets
okay let's
can we go to the lady uh in the
pink top with a hand up i'm not going to
talk about your hair color because i've
got a trouble for that but you've got
the microphone thank you um you've
outlined some very innovative policies
how are you going to get anything
through when your government can't even
get the civil service back into the
office and the civil service at the top
is people entirely by remainers
well what what i can say is it it takes
leadership it takes leadership from the
prime minister
and from secretaries of state in their
department to make sure things get done
and in every single job i've had in
government you know the trade department
the
the foreign office i have made sure the
things got done i mean civil servants
there are some civil servants who
uh
who who do spend a lot of time working
from home for example that is certainly
true but
what i will say about the foreign office
is people work round the clock you know
people were in every weekend after
russia invaded ukraine helping british
citizens get out of ukraine helping uh
get the new sanctions regime in place
and working extremely hard do we have
some really talented and dedicated civil
servants what's important is that we
have the leadership that's clear about
what we expect and if people don't
deliver then they do need to be moved on
and that is something that i've been
prepared to do as a secretary of state
and i would absolutely be prepared to do
as prime minister
let's uh
let's go upstairs
we've only got a few more we'll try and
squeeze many impossible uh how about the
gentleman with his hand up here in a
short sleeve shirt and he's holding a
ready for rishi poster
i think he can be turned though don't
you
let's see
i'm staying in this camp thank you
my question to you liz is
with your trade deals you've done with
um
australia new zealand
speaking as a farmer a lot of farmers
are worried for the future
simply because with a tariff that will
be terrorists that we lowered
which means we'll get more and more
uh meat coming into this country
will that mean be coming into the
into the sectors like restaurants and
uh trains and aeroplanes where the
public courts eat
and will it be to the same standards as
our extractor
i think that the beef and lamb we
produce in britain is absolutely world
beating and i'm proud of the fact that
it used to be banned in the united
states market but i got access for our
beef and lamb into the united states is
now being enjoyed there and we're now
selling more and more of it around the
world i think our quality
is a premium product it's absolutely
unbeatable in terms of the trade deals i
struck with australia and new zealand
i'm proud of those deals the fact is
before we joined the european union we
used to buy a lot of produce from
australia and new zealand they were some
of our closest allies and our closest
partners we closed the door to them when
we joined the european union and all
we're giving them now is the same access
to our market that the eu have but in 15
years time and there are protections and
there are safeguards for our farmers but
i'm proud of the deal that we've struck
with our very close allies i think it's
right that we righted the wrongs of what
we did back in the 1970s
okay
very last question of clay that is
almost time up to the gentleman sitting
in the very front row waving his hand
wearing the jacket he's got a rich watch
on he's not carrying a placard i know
that doesn't narrow him down somebody
would lose trust on their t-shirt please
i don't want to make it easy for you
sir
good evening uh
liz you spoke about increasing defense
spending to three percent of gdp
could i therefore ask will your
government reverse its decision
uh to cut 10 000 personnel from our
armed forces by 2025
at a time when nato has a major conflict
on its border in ukraine
well
i do think we need to rethink our
security at this very very difficult
moment and what i have said is i will
review the integrated review and look at
the increased threat from russia and
also the increased threat from a
assertive china and that is why i'm
talking about increasing our defense
spending to three percent of gdp of
course it'll have to be further work to
see
exactly how that will be spent
but what is clear from what is happening
in ukraine is that land wars in europe
are not something of the past deeply
regrettably they are something that we
are facing now so we do need to look at
that again i will work very closely with
the defense secretary on that
okay so
i'm sorry there's some more hands up but
i hope that really is time it one time
tiny thing i want to do before you will
go and you'll remember i asked you to
raise your hand when you came in here if
you were undecided
please now raise your hand if you are
still undecided between liz and rishi
well that's fascinating so that looks
like i'd say 10 to 15 percent are now
undecided down from 40 percent
when uh so someone has changed your
minds don't tell me who because i'll get
into trouble just cast your votes
folks that is it thank you so much for
listening thank you listen to me thank
you
you